hello
everybody welcome i'm alice kaplan
director of the whitney humanities
center and professor of french and
francophone studies at yale
welcome to this webinar celebrating the
re-issue
this summer of william gardner-smith's
1963 novel
the stone face i'm grateful to the
whitney
to the yale center for the study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
and the department of french and
francophone studies for their support
we'll be looking at a novel that has
been out of print for so many years
as issues at its center racism
police violence and war and memory have
taken center stage in both
france and the u.s i'd like to briefly
introduce
our three panelists each of them an
important
voice on these issues adam
schatz is a contributing editor at the
london review of books and a contributor
to the new york times magazine the new
york review of books in the new yorker
he is one of the very keenest analysts
of algerian politics and literature
whether he's writing about kamel
dawood's fiction
or the legacy of french torture in the
algerian war
adam last visited yale in 2019
to lecture on franz fano his
2019 new yorker article how does it feel
to be a white man
william gardner smith's exile was
important in bringing the stone face to
public attention but most important of
all
adam has written the introduction to the
forthcoming
new york review books edition of the
stone face
tyler stovall is a french historian
whose work on the red belt
suburbs of paris on the history of
racism in france
on post-colonial and transnational
history
have defined a field i'll mention just
two of his
many books paranoia
americans in the city of light where i
first learned about the stone face
and his newest white freedom the racial
history of an idea
where he explores the centrality of
white racial identity
to an understanding of freedom he has
served as dean of the humanities at uc
santa cruz and is president of the
american historical association
he is currently dean of the graduate
school of arts and sciences
at fordham leah brosgall
is associate professor of french and
francophone studies in the department of
european language and trans-cultural
studies
at the university of california los
angeles
her book absent the archive cultural
traces of a massacre in paris
17 october 1961 just published by
liverpool university press
maps through a series of brilliant
cultural analyses
the afterlife of the october 17
massacres
of algerians in paris a state crime that
was censored officially
but that survived through the work of
artists and writers like william
gardner-smith
leah has lectured at yale on the
representation of october
17 and she was a much appreciated
speaker in my war and memory seminar
this fall
so here's how we're structuring the hour
first uh introductory remarks to set up
our conversation
adam schatz will talk about william
gardner-smith tyler stovall will discuss
paranoia and the black expatriate
literary scene
then liam rose gaul will talk about the
october 17
massacre and its representation in the
stone face and other works
after these introductory remarks will go
into
dialogue leaving 10 or 15 minutes at the
end for audience questions
so please feel free to submit questions
throughout the hour
in the q and a panel and check the chat
where we'll be posting
references to works mentioned wherever
possible
so adam i'll pass the floor to you now
uh thank you so much alice for that uh
warm and generous uh introduction it's a
pleasure to be here
uh speaking uh with uh tyler staval and
leah brosgal
two historians um
i admire a great deal
i first became aware of william gardner
smith's
novel the stone face which was published
in 1963
about a decade or so ago um
via a friend of mine a scholar at
columbia brent hayes edwards who has
written extensively on the literature of
the black diaspora
and uh and then i began to come upon
references
to gardner smith's work uh in
tyler stovall's magnificent history of
black expatriates in paris uh paranoia
and in the work of kristin ross and i
ordered a copy of the book
uh because i was intrigued and in fact
astonished
by the fact that the first fictional
depiction of the october 17 1961
massacre of algerian protesters
by the paris police had been written by
a black american expatriate novelist
in the introduction to to this uh
this book i described gardner smith as a
long forgotten novelist
um but in order to be a forgotten you
have to have been remembered and i don't
think and gardner smith was always a
very obscure figure
so i became very curious about uh who
gardner smith was
um he was born in uh 1927
uh in philadelphia he grew up in a poor
neighborhood of black philadelphia and
by the time he was in his teens
he had experienced terrible beatings
by the police he became
a journalist at a very young age at 17
he was hired by the pittsburgh
courier one of the most important black
newspapers
in america and not long after
he ended up going to germany
with the american military he served
there just after the war
for about eight months and on his return
at the age of 22 he published a striking
novel
um called last of the conquerors it was
published by uh ferrari strauss and
giroux
and it's about a a black soldier uh in
germany
who uh paradoxically finds uh
freedom for the first time in the arms
of a white german woman
in a country uh that had just recently
slaughtered
millions of people on racial grounds and
when i read this book which is a very
uh lyrical account of a romance and also
a devastating treatment of racism
in the american army it struck me that
gardner smith was someone who was
at one of the same time very interested
in issues of
social justice and racism and at the
same time
uh attracted to complexity and
difficulty
and uh one of the one of his great
preoccupations
was the question of belonging which is
at the center
of his novel of the stone face about uh
a young uh black american journalist
simeon brown
30 years of age who comes to paris and
at first
experiences it as a kind of paradise and
falls into the soft embrace of the black
expatriate scene
at the cafe de tourno around writers
in inspired by figures like richard
wright and chester himes
richard gibson but then simeon brown
realizes that in fact
there are people who are treated much
like black
americans were back home and they were
algerians
neither black nor white and he's drawn
into the algerian liberation struggle he
arrives in 1960
and a year later he witnesses the
october 17
uh massacre uh james baldwin
in his uh essay on richard wright
published just after uh wright's death
the last poor richard
lamented uh that wright had
become complacent about french racism he
uh had begun to enjoy what it was like
to be
a white man uh in paris i think it was
somewhat unfair of baldwin in fact
richard wright did write
about uh french racism uh but
uh this is this this in this essay
baldwin reflects on what he calls the
hazards of expatriation
he never wrote that novel although he
did comment on the problem in some of
his essays
uh gardner smith is the one who wrote
that
novel and it's has a very french theme
at the same time because the theme is
fraternity what defines brotherhood
and what we find in the stone face
is that it is not skin color it is not
race
it is ethical action it is solidarity
and in the case of simeon brown it means
disaffiliating
from other black expatriates and joining
up
with algerians uh it's a rather
bitter account of the black expatriate
scene not
what we're really accustomed to so
now i'm going to turn the turn the table
over turn the floor over
to tyler stovall who is really our our
leading expert
on black expatriates in paris thank you
very much
thank you adam um and thank you alice
for this wonderful introduction and for
organizing this event and thank you to
the whitney center at yale
um i just want to follow up a bit on a
few of the things
adam said about the stone face and
william gardner-smith and put it into a
broader uh historical con context
of the whole history of
african-americans in
uh paris in the 20th century this is a
this is a community that i mean had long
antecedents but really began to take
shape as a
defined community in the years after the
first world war
um the first world war had brought the
first mass
presence of african americans some two
thousand two hundred thousand
to france and in in the american army
and um
almost all of them of course went back
home but a few stayed
and uh african-americans stayed partly
because they had introduced jazz to
france and they were able to use it as a
way of
surviving in fact prospering in the
country during the nineteen twenties
during the
lasagne fog um and it's when they first
began to develop a geographical
community in the neighborhood of
montmartre
in in northern paris so this is a
community that had you know by the 1930s
and certainly by the 1940s
had a real sense of itself and it
developed a sense of itself
as creating a role in a friend in a
foreign nation that was very hospitable
very enthusiastic about african-american
culture in contrast
to the situation of african americans in
the united states
so thus began what i've called the myth
of colorblind paris
the idea that paris was a city free of
racism and then in particular paris was
a city that welcomed with open arms
african americans after the second world
war
this community uh renewed itself it had
disappeared during the second week
during the war itself all the
african-americans had left virtually
but many came back after the second
world war and they reinstalled the
community this time as more of a
literary community
headed up by richard wright
excuse me and um this is the community
that william gardner smith
joined in 1960.
so and it was a very fascinating
community william gardner smith
found himself in the heart of what was
in many ways the heart of black
intelligentsia
and certainly the heart of the black
literary world in the 1950s and the
1960s
and yet william gardner-smith also
represents a broader turning point
in this the life of this community if
you will the sort of
decline of the idea of france is a
colorblind nation
because if he comes to france at a time
of you know
of a great welcoming of african
americans he also comes to france in the
middle of the algerian war
france's great uh anti-colonial struggle
and it's worth reminding people that
france was involved in anti-colonial
wars from basically 1946 when it began
the war to
repress the vietnamese struggle for
independence until 1962.
so this was a major theme in french
history
and it is william gardner-smith that
brings an awareness
of the this aspect of french life which
includes
an awareness of french racism to the
eyes of african-americans and to
americans in general so
he is the one that more than anybody
else really calls into question
and ultimately destroys the myth of
colorblind france
points out that um france in many ways
has his own kinds of racism
just as much as the united states does
and
is very explicitly drawn to an
assessment of this
he is also the one who in doing so
really draws together
two of the great movements for justice
of the post-war world
uh the movement for civil rights in the
united states and the movement for
decolonization
in uh africa and asia and europe
these two movements have a lot in common
and the stone face is one that makes
that uh
commonality explicit by exploring the
ways in which an african-american
would see himself drawn to anti-colonial
struggles and see them as part of his
own struggle the the classic statement
how does it feel to be a white man
really it's very complex because it
basically is reforms richard uh
forms william gardner smith's way of
saying that racist is positional it is
not an absolute
but race and racism depend on time and
place
and one can be racially uh excluded in
one context
and very much a part of the racial
superstructure and part of the racial
hierarchy in another context
and so it's it's a fascinating novel
that looks at the ways in which racism
is defined
both in the united states and in france
and then there's the whole issue of its
portrayal of the october 17
1961 demonstration when i first lived in
france it was
uh some 40 years ago and i remembered
reading liberation on october 17th 1981
the 20th anniversary
of the demonstration librarian had a big
three-page spread
about it uh and it was portrayed in
terms that emphasized over and over
again how
virtually nobody in france even knew
that this history existed and i found
that to be true when i asked people
i met and nobody had ever heard of it
and some people said that librasian was
lying
it did not actually exist so
this demonstration forms a fascinating
plot device
in the stone phase it really brings
together
uh william gardner's missed arguments
about racism algeria and the united
states
but it was also of course a real
historical event
and the fact that it occurred and the
fact that he was able to integrate it
into his novel
showed just how important not just this
incident but the whole
relationship between american racism
against african-americans
and french racism against algerians
between uh decolonization and civil
rights struggle
how important that relationship was and
how determined it was
of the 20th century mid-20th century and
as a whole
as a whole so i want to now pass the
floor on to professor
uh leah broskat who's going to talk a
bit more
about october 17th
thank you tyler for that perfect segue
i came to the stone face through my work
on the cultural representations
of the october 17th police massacre of
algerian demonstrators
so i'm going to make a couple of points
about how this episode is represented in
william gardner-smith's novel
but also try to offer some broader
information about how literature
film and other cultural texts have
stepped in to fill
the void in knowledge surrounding
october 17th
as tyler just mentioned even in 1981
the general discourse in france
regarding this event was that nobody
knew
or nobody had seen or that the event
itself had somehow been
invisible despite the fact that it took
place
in the center of paris on a tuesday
evening
so there are um there are three texts
that belong to what i have called the
sort of first wave of cultural
representation of october 17th
that is three cultural texts that
attempt to represent october 17th in the
immediate aftermath of the heat of the
action
the first cultural text if you will is a
documentary film
an hour-long documentary film called
october
october in paris by an amateur filmmaker
named jack
panigel the second is a poem
written by ketev yasin who is often
considered the duane of algerian letters
the poem was written in french and it's
called in french non-liguil dulu
which is best translated into english as
in the jaws of the wolf
and both of these both the documentary
and the poem focus wholly on october
17th
the stone face however is the only
fictional work uh
from this time period of the early 1960s
and the premise of the novel interesting
is not ostensibly october 17th
and indeed within the novel october 17th
the massacre
that took place on october 17th 1961
doesn't really take up that much space
it represents less than 10 pages of of
prose in a novel that's slightly over
200 pages long
and yet the slenderness of this chapter
i think belies the significance of
october 17th
historically for the protagonist simeon
brown of the
faced and in terms of the cultural
production of
of october 17th so historically i'd just
like to point out that october 17th
wasn't just any protest and
really can't be swept aside as just
another bump in the turbulent decade
that was the algerian war
this was really a significant episode of
state-sponsored violence
it stands to this day as the deadliest
episode of colonial violence to take
place on metropolitan soil
and it remains the bloodiest day in
paris since world war ii
now interestingly some of our some of
our listeners might recall headlines
following the
terror attacks that took place in
november uh november 2015 in paris
often the headlines after that day uh
consecrated it as the deadliest day in
paris since world war ii
and in fact that can only be true if you
sort of bracket off
october 17th um and this is this is
interesting in so far as it really
embodies the ways in which this day
and the the violence of october 17th
have kind of been bracketed uh within
the french historical
record so the novel the stone face comes
to its dramatic conclusion with the
events of october 17th making it really
the paroxysm of this novel and despite
having been warned not to get involved
with uh the events our protagonist
simeon goes out into paris that night
um and he witnesses in central paris
firsthand thousands of algerian
protesters some 20 000 algerian
protesters
processing through iconic parisian
neighborhoods and boulevards
and then he witnesses the brutality of
the police repression and
indeed the conditions of detention as
simeon himself
steps in to try and protect an algerian
woman
who's being beaten by a parisian police
officer
as she tries to protect her infant son
from from the blows
and so simeon in fact experiences
october 17th as both
a witness to the uh the violence and in
certain ways as a kind of victim of the
violence as well
he's beaten by the police before he's
summarily thrown into a paddy wagon and
taken to a holding center
um a sports stadium that had been
converted into a temporary holding
center for algerians
and where he spends the night witnessing
the conditions
of the um of the algerian in prison
and then finds himself released from the
stadium
due once again to the type of odd
privilege he's experienced throughout
the novel that is
as being considered privileged and
powerful as compared to
the algerians and so in a way we also
see that
october 17th is a catalyst for his own
political thinking
his own soul-searching the
soul-searching he's been engaged with
throughout the novel
soul-searching about race and racism his
place in france and his displacement
from the united states
all of this comes to a head with his
experience
of october 17th and he finally comes to
the conclusion
that it's time to leave paris
um i want to observe also that october
17th
in within the context of a novel that is
largely
realistic and plausible october 17th
is the only actual historical event that
is mentioned and narrated in great
detail
indeed we really feel gardner smith's
background as a journalist coming out in
this passage
it's deeply sort of invested in a kind
of documentary reportage he gives
tons of evidence including place names
in paris and
and sites of the violence and yet
curiously he gets the date
wrong we don't know whether this is
intentional or or
a typo but in fact gardner smith writes
on october 1st 1961
the algerian national liberation front
called on algerians living in paris to
go into the streets and hold a
demonstration
so there's something very curious about
the way in which he
we think deliberately um misrepresents
the date um and we can talk about that
perhaps in the q a a little bit
um i want to just say a few more things
about um
how the stone face functions within the
context of representation
as tyler mentioned this was the very
first novel
to narrativize the events of uh of
october 17th
interestingly it's an american novel uh
it would take until 1983
uh to uh to see the first french novel
published that represent these events
this is a book called northrop
memoir or murder in memoriam by dj
danangs
and then it would probably take in my
estimation until 2005 before we get
really
the sort of broadest circulating work
cultural work to represent october 17th
and that would be the film cachet by the
australia
austrian director mikhail hanika which
came out in 2005
and while it doesn't represent the
events in terms of
um and so forth it doesn't reproduce the
the repression and the massacre
it does make interesting side long
reference to the events of october 17th
in a way that really embodies and
crystallizes uh the way the event itself
has sort of lived in
in the shadows of french history and in
in the shadows of discourse
uh so the stone face um one of the most
interesting things about it i think
is um the way it it so clearly testifies
to how visible the violence would have
been
in paris on that tuesday evening and
indeed how threatening the spectacle
of algerian political sovereignty and
subjectivity
would have been to the nation at the
time
it also gives a sense of how how
discourse at the time was absolutely
crackling with race talk
and this is something you don't have to
rely on the novel for this although the
novel does a very good job of it
but we can also confirm this through um
contemporary materials from the press
and through archival materials
and this is important to underscore
because it allows us to construct
october 17th also as a racially
motivated episode of state terror and
police violence
which is extremely important to ongoing
conversations about
truth and uh reconciliation in france
and it also makes the stone face even
more so
a key text for comparative transnational
study
i just wanted to end on um if i might on
a quote from
the the novel towards the very very end
that i think is um
incredibly prescient and so as simeon
has announced to
his french friends that he's going to be
leaving uh one of his friends says to
him
don't go you'll see as soon as the
algerian war is over everything in
france will be good again
and to this simeon replies and i quote
it's a long time before things will be
good here again
france really hasn't even begun to
suffer yet from the things that happened
during this war
i think in the context of a france where
we have recently seen a report
commissioned by the president on how to
effect some kind of uh change in
franco-algerian relationships this is
the storage
report i think we can read simeon's
comment as indeed incredibly resonant to
this day
and so with that i'll invite alice and
the rest of the panel's
a panelist back to the forum so that we
can exchange about this
this novel and its implications
thank you so much all of you you're so
succinct and
you you make me want to ask so many
questions
i think i'd like to start with simeon uh
with simian with the text before we move
into the
the political and ethical issues um
first of all why the stone face
what about that title and how does it
set up
you know the various premises of the
novel
well oh go ahead adam no no please no i
was just i was just going to say i think
the stone face is a symbol of
man's inhumanity to man um i think
there's also a sartre in reference there
um but i'm not a literary scholar so i'm
not sure but
yeah i mean i think you know the stone
face one of the most arresting
parts of descriptions of the novel and i
think again something that's
historically based
in the description of october 17th is he
he shows a policeman beating up a woman
and her child right and just the idea
that somebody could do that
shows how inhuman how that shows they
must have a face made of stone it seems
okay i mean he's he's in fact working on
a painting he's painting uh
right right he's painting the stone face
which is a reference to this experience
that he had of being
brutalized in fact one of his eyes was
was gouged out
there's a patch on his eye his eye he
was he was blind half-blinded by
um in a racist attack back in the states
right it made me think of watching the
face of chauvin as the verdict was
announced with his ass looking at it
looking at his eyes and trying to find
something in those eyes
right yeah i mean it functions as this
kind of recurring late motif in the
novel for the face of racism right he
ascribes it first to
the young boy who as adam said gouges
out his eye
later to a police officer in
philadelphia who
who beats him uh senseless
and with each of these events of violent
racism he experiences
he he says that he sees again this face
it's always the same face
the stone face the face of racism he
sees this again
in the french police officer who is who
is beating the algerian woman
and as adam also mentioned he is he's an
amateur painter in the novel and so he's
also trying to paint
the the stone face and interestingly one
of the
in fact the culminating paragraph of the
novel uh has him
uh slashing up the canvas of the
painting of the stone face
as he has decided to return to the
united states bought his ticket booked
passage and is ready to go
so there's a kind of there's a certain i
hate to say there's a certain triteness
to the way this is handled in the book
um but but that's also part of the the
way in which he's tried to pull through
this thread
of what the face of racism looks like
and how he reacts to it and that's
what's kind of
both dated and charming about the novel
it is it is quite a didactic fiction
uh about this please deconstruct this
growing awareness that he has
about the stone face and uh uh the
notion that the stone
face is the same everywhere which is you
know his realization toward the end of
the novel
uh was in fact common to uh depictions
of
of october 17 as as leah knows um
i remember uh in the film by panigel
um there are references to um
uh to the holocaust in it and uh
right and of course later on we discover
in the late 90s
at the time of the uh of the papuan
trial
that the paris prefect who was presiding
over this massacre
was guilty not only of of of war crimes
in algeria where he
served as an official but also during
the vichy period
of the deportations that's right the old
multi-dimensional
memory is multi-directional memory very
much
in operation here for sure in some ways
it's a novel about how you translate
racism
how he translates the racism of his his
youth
uh in his experience of paris and how
different and yet how much the same yeah
right sorry leah go ahead
no i'm sorry i was going to say it just
interesting to note that in two out of
these three
cultural texts from right after uh the
october 17th massacre we have these
comparative gestures with world war ii
and the holocaust
not just in the documentary as as adam
mentioned
but also in the stone face insofar as
simian is involved with a woman who
is a survivor of the holocaust a polish
jew
who has whose parents have been murdered
who herself was a victim of sexual
violence at the hands of a nazi officer
and so again this idea that the
comparison
um the comparative gestures there not
just in terms of a transnational
look across the atlantic ocean but also
looking to
uh the holocaust as well and there's
that incredible scene where
where an algerian guy is expressing his
feelings of racist
rage about the truth of algeria right
computers collaborators
ours and so on so no one has really
spared a guilty conscience in history
and simeon himself uh we it seems has
participated in something that is
described as
not quite a rape but like a rape
a teenager right yeah in a flashback
yeah no no it's interesting because that
whole link with the holocaust of world
war ii also exists in murder and
memorial
yeah right um and in some ways it sort
of flips the script because
with uh with the popcorn trial it starts
with pokemon trial for his complicity in
the holocaust and only then does it
emerge
the whole history of october 17. in
murder memoriam it's sort of the reverse
exactly uh where you first see that
october 17th massacre and then gradually
becomes aware of his
participation holocaust yeah yeah i
remember verges was trying to make hay
with that
um and and make france incapable of
judging
anybody because of its own lack of
morals right
yeah that's very interesting can we now
skip
to the end of the novel which has been
much
debated and there's a very brilliant
section in leah's book about
about the decision by simeon which is so
different
simeon decides to return to the u.s and
join the movement
yet when gardner smith goes to ghana
um and this has occasioned a debate
including by paul gilroy who thinks that
returning the united states is something
of a cop-out
uh leah do you want to take that on it's
such an interesting
it's fascinating i mean i'm not sure why
characters would have to follow the
trajectories of their authors or vice
versa
um my understanding though is that um
originally gardner smith had
written the novel's ending with uh
simeon
uh staying in france or perhaps going to
africa but that it was
um at the suggestion of his editor at
ferrari strauss
giroud that he he was highly encouraged
to return
simeon to the united states um so this
might be one of those instances where
the
editorial hand weighed heavier than what
the author's original desires or
intentions might have been
um but indeed paul gilroy has criticized
this ending he calls it a kind of
capitulation to narrow demands of
kinship
um and it's sort of interesting to see
how the the trajectories of
simeon brown and and william garner
smith are then cleaved apart
right um william gardner-smith goes to
ghana for a time
where he lives and is involved with um
with uh liberation struggles and then
eventually returns to france where he
lives out
the rest of his unfortunately short life
um
i i think i think it's a little bit of a
shame to judge the return of simeon
brown so harshly i'm i'm not sure
exactly that it capitulates to anything
on the one hand
it separates simeon brown from his um
compatriots the other
black americans in exile in paris but it
returns him to
to his homeland to participate in a
struggle
and i think william it seems that
william gardner smith what we know from
his correspondence is that
the decision to stay the decision not to
go back to the united states was
something
that um that haunted him and that he
wrote in in letters to his mother for
example that
although he felt comfortable in france
he also felt uncomfortable because he
couldn't be political
he couldn't engage he was constantly
reminded that it wasn't his place to
engage in the political struggles
in in france um and and this this does
seem to have been
something that weighed on his conscience
quite a bit we also know that several
his other works were translated into
french and the understanding is that he
never tried to have the stone face
translated into french
because he knew he was dealing with a
kind of political dynamite and that it
would just
get him into trouble i didn't realize
that that was partly his desire
because we've all wondered why it hasn't
been translated it's now
in translation at the end
it's coming out in october
next october so it will finally exist in
the french context will be very
interesting to follow the
reviews and so on absolutely
yeah um i mean one of the things that
interests me about this question alice
is that
in some ways the idea that simeon would
return to the united states is the
most fitting end to the novel the way it
takes shape
i mean if you see the novels or novels
as a repudiation
of the politics of exile and an emphasis
on the
unity of world struggles well why
shouldn't he go back to the united
states
you know why shouldn't he go back to a
place where he can be politically active
but the point is as you say that first
of all he william gardner smith the
author did not do that
um many others did not do that as well i
mean
all you have to do is look at james
baldwin who was one of
the biggest critics of people like
richard wright
well james baldwin spent most of the
rest of his life in the french riviera
right
he went back to america from time to
time to give talks and so on and so
forth but he never went back
to become politically involved in it
permanently in america so
you know it does say something about the
the attraction of this kind of
experience even for those people that in
many ways reject it
politically no adam said something
he did i mean of course a baldwin did go
back at a at a critical
juncture he went back in 1957 um and he
writes about
that sense of survivor's guilt and why
he felt moved
uh to return particularly in no name in
the street
i i i think gilroy i think gilroy's
essay is brilliant but
um i i i don't see how returning
uh to the states to become involved in
the civil rights movement 19
you know in the early 1960s uh uh
in 1963 and in 1961 this novel could
have been a capitulation
and in fact um in this novel he says
the reason he's returning is to
uh join forces with america's algerians
but the experience of exile has
nourished his thinking
and has allowed him to place the black
american experience in a wider context
of anti-colonial
liberation struggles but has widened his
perspective and he feels the same
uh desire i think that leads
his friend ahmed a young kabil
medical student uh to uh
leave france and to fight in the in the
mountains of cabelia
with uh with the fln so i think it is
consistent at the same time
we do know um that originally
uh simeon brown uh decides to go to
africa
in fact there are conversations in the
novel with african students
none of whom is named why don't you come
build an independent african state with
us you're needed there you'll be
comfortable among your people
um that's the kinship uh but but but he
does but he doesn't go to africa of
course
i think that was in fact um a request of
his editor at fsg
um i don't see it as a capitulation i
see it's because he's going
under a very different uh very different
pretext
uh he's not simply going home he sees
home in a different light
yeah and not to belabor the point but
narratively it's totally coherent right
i mean we see
simeon brown sort of beginning to
imagine himself involved
in in sort of analogous struggles i'm
just going to quote he
he imagined himself on an algerian
mountain fighting alongside ahmed then
he imagined himself in angola fighting
with the nationalists
or in the congo aiding the imprisoned
prime minister of paris lumumba
then he returned with an ache to reality
and there's also on the micro level the
setup of um
the the little girl in arkansas who he
sees being prohibited from going into
the school
and then the children he see the
algerian children he sees in the streets
with their mothers
being threatened by police and so on
sort of the micro narrative level and in
terms of all the parallel rooms that are
set up
it's coherent um that that simeon would
make this move
yeah you seem to be implying that he
actually does
learn something from his transnational
experience of racism
it brings to mind a passage that
we've talked about where simeon
is i guess he's on a bus and he starts
thinking of harlem he's in paris and he
thinks of harlem
we actually think sarah do you have the
passage so that you can share the screen
great adam do you feel like reading sure
i can
um northward toward heart toward harlem
the further north the bus moved the more
drab became the buildings the streets
and the people
cheap stores selling clothes furniture
kitchen utensils
easy terms 10 months to pay cafes became
dimmer the streets narrower and noisier
more and more children filled the
sidewalks men
out of work with nothing to do and no
place to go stood in sullen
feudal groups on street corners arab
music blared from the dark cafes or from
the open windows of bleak hotels
then suddenly police were everywhere
stalking the streets
eyes moving insolently from face to face
sub machine guns strung from their
shoulders
it was like harlem simian thought except
that there were fewer cops in harlem but
maybe that too would come one day
like harlem and like all the ghettos of
the world the men he saw through the
window of the bus had whiter skins
and less frizzy hair but they were in
other ways like the negros in the united
states
they adopted the same poses stashing on
corners
ready for and scared of the ever
possible
trouble eyes sullen and distrusting
dressed in pegged pants flashy shirts
and narrow pointed shoes
he could almost hear them saying what
you putting down man
just playing it cool just playing it
cool man trying to keep old charlie off
my back
old charlie paced the street waving his
submachine gun
street vendors shouted their wares in
arabic fruit
clothes vegetables he remembered the
push carts in his childhood on 10th
street
the sweating men plugging holes in
watermelon so you could taste them
opening fish and cleaning them and
scaling them for you shouting in the
mornings
any old rags any papers any iron the
odors of rotting food and of cooking
mingled in the air and he remembered how
they had smelled him
the fried chicken or the greens the
uncollected garbage in the alleys and
gutters
arab music assailed them from all sides
the blues
where was the blue singer now in the
dismal cafes men
played pinball or football machines or
stood at counters staring at nothing
empty cups in front of them there were
no women the police
pace the streets their face is hard
thank you so much though in the hard
faces there's the lay motif of the stone
face right
it's one of the most written passages i
think in a novel that uses
dialogue i think often as a kind of
paddle boat to get somewhere in an
argument i mean this is
very very literary
and and layered
and after that passage he writes that um
that simeon um expected to be seen
as a brother but in fact he's not he's
he's an outsider
and he's suspect not just because he's
not
algerian but also because he's american
too right
well what do you have described this
novel as the
novel of the guilty bystander
um you agree
well i was i was gonna mention the one
of the other famous passages
in um in the book where samina's walking
past the group of
algerians and one yells out hey how's it
how does it feel to be a white man
of course no algerian in paris would
ever have said that to an african
american in the 1960s right
this is not an algerian speaking this is
simeon speaking
unconscious speaking for himself
that you know in other words all the the
freedom of paris that he's been
luxuriated yet
is really not freedom at all it's really
white privilege okay
he doesn't use those words but that
that's clearly what it is
and it's one of the first novels i know
that that makes that point
so clearly in an international context
well i mean why don't we we're going to
switch to the
audience questions soon but i want to
ask you to
end what does this novel have to tell us
today
how does it fit into the current debate
i think you address some of those issues
adam in your
in your preface about you know the
current
the current trouble over identity
politics versus universalism
i mean what position does this novel
take
well i i on the one hand it's very much
an anti-racist novel and on the other
hand on the other hand
it's a rather subtle critique of a
politics based
narrowly on an identity as as tyler uh
pointed out earlier
um even the notion of of of race
is is situational um he's
he is not black in the way that he is
black in america
once he is in paris um it's it's the
algerians who occupy
uh that position um and he becomes aware
of course
that that is um his black brothers so to
speak
uh the the writers the cafe de tour
non-circle
have um have uh become quite complacent
about the privilege
that they are enjoying in paris um and
and would prefer not uh to be associated
with this despised minority
so um in order to to to move into
solidarity with the algerians he has to
disaffiliate
from people around the cafe of toronto
the black expatriates
so um to me it it's very much a novel
about
the the grounds the ethical grounds um
of fraternity um and solidarity
and a critique of the notion that that
um that that that race is a sufficient
grounds for that kind of solidarity
um it also places race in a much more
international
uh context in the context of uh in this
case of decolonization
so um in that sense i think it's it's
it's refreshing
refreshingly uh heterodoxy it cuts
against
i think some of the um
some of the the rigid and essentialist
thinking about
about identity that um has become
unfortunately i think a reflex um in
in the states in recent years yes yeah
leah i'm thinking about um all the work
you've done on the invisibility and
visibility
of the 17th of october and the way
that he makes it visible versus the way
that
state violence and police violence is
visible today and how that
has changed oh well i mean of course
i think you know
one of the obvious things is technology
there we have this we have this
fictionalized account
of william gardner smith in the voice of
simeon brown but obviously william
gardner smith witnessed what happened on
october 17th
and recounted it in this novel um
but we do know and we have now the
evidence that
photographs were taken that night
there's photographic documentary
evidence of
the police violence um if it had
happened today we would have body cams
we would have instant release of this
kind of footage these things would
become memes they would be posted on
social media
clearly in 1961 that's not an option
um and indeed the photographs that were
taken by journalists circulating in
paris that night were
were censored by the government so while
some of them made their way into the
press before the press was fully
censored
most of them weren't seen until decades
after the events themselves
so there's a certain interesting way in
which comparing with today you know
technology
makes things visible in a way that it
couldn't have in 1961.
despite that huge banner across the
sands saying
they drown algeria and that's also a
fantastic story because
um numerous accusatory graffiti were
painted along the sand in the weeks
after october 17th
and yet they were as soon as they were
discovered they were guarded by the
police so that people couldn't take
pictures of them ostensibly
and we have one photograph of one of
these graffiti
that was taken by an amateur
photographer who happened to
crop out when he took the photograph he
happened to be able to crop out the
jean down who were guarding the tag
so it's an extraordinary document that
also didn't see the light of day until i
think 1986
when lumenite published its 25th
anniversary special
uh coverage of october 17th
yeah i want i want to make another point
about october 17th which at times
is uh not addressed but i'm
going back to my history my own history
as a historian of paris suburbs
because in many ways october 17th is an
invasion of the city by the suburbs
of algerian communities and other
communities living outside paris
coming in invading the heart of the city
and being destroyed precisely because
they are in a place where they do not
belong
and this is all happening at a time when
both indepe both the independence of
algeria and the reorganization of the
greater paris area are happening at the
same time so in fact
the three new departments that are
created outside paris
are given numbers from the free former
algerian departments once algeria
becomes independent
right so so there's a sense in which you
know the paris suburbs are the new
post-colonial france
right exactly yeah yeah and you know in
in and and
just to i want to just piggyback on that
point tyler
um there there is a a major
demonstration
that takes place in february of 1962
but the demonstrators are white white
french people in the country
in the communist party orbit at the
metron
eight demonstrators are killed and
that's what gets remembered
massacre it's not october 17. yeah right
right that's yeah it's interesting
go ahead just to piggyback off both of
those if i might um
it's it's true that um proportionally
most of the algerian demonstrators that
came into paris that night lived outside
of paris lived in the suburbs lived in
the
the large slum that was right but
significant numbers also lived within
the city limits but were invisible right
so the event is often figured when it
was figured in the press as a kind of
invasion of the capital right the taking
of the capital from forces coming from
without
ignoring in fact that large numbers of
algerians lived
at within the city limits but weren't
seen
to the public until they emerged in this
kind of spectacular demonstration on
october 17th
yeah i mean people that lived in the
chamber de bun for example on the top
right
right right or you know five men to a
bed
back in the days when paris actually had
mixed classes because of themselves
right all right exactly listen we've got
some interesting questions
and a little bit of time um was gardner
smith
influenced by false final who like him
connected his thinking about racism and
the black condition
to anti-colonial struggle and in
particular the algerian war of
independence
you know it's interesting you you will
not find
even in uh his work of reportage return
to black america which was uh published
in
i think 1970 and it's quite an
interesting book a single reference
uh to fanon there's there are no
references to found out he i mean he
might have been aware
that he was certainly aware of the
wretched of the earth
perhaps also a black skin white mat
black skin white mask uh
rest of the earth was published in
december of um of
1961 1961 this novel appeared in 63
so likely he knew it uh that there is a
chapter in the book
uh where he meets two young algerian
women who've been tortured back home
and and one of the women says that
uh because we've contributed to the
algerian struggle we can now choose our
own husbands
and we will never go back to wearing the
veil now of course this is a very
turns out to be a very optimistic
understanding of what's going to happen
in post-independence algeria
but it's a it's a it's an account that
exactly mirrors
uh fanan's description of algerian women
in
year five of the algerian revolution or
dying colonialism the essay algeria
unveiled
right so um my sense is that he probably
was
familiar with fandom but there are no
traces uh
no explicit traces of funnel in his work
final didn't have a presence in paris in
those years right
i mean he was no no when he left he he
left paris and
sorry he left lyon in in in late 1953
returned very very briefly uh on his way
to tunis in
late 1956 and never came back so no but
but but it but uh but
francois maspiro the left-wing publisher
uh published uh
uh you know lost signs and then donated
latter
so he did he had a small presence in an
activist community
right and people who were part of the of
the uh de valise circle the people who
were in the jean-son network who were
aiding the algerian rebels
they knew about his work and in fact
there is a character in the stone face
named ahri a frenchman
who is this the one frenchman who admits
that there is a problem with racism
by the end of the novel he's working
with the prophet
network we have a question
about how much um william garcia's life
corresponded to the life of simeon in
the novel
i mean things i imagine the question
could involve things like the
relationship with
maria with a jewish holocaust survivor
or
um i i i think that well there is a
certain parallel
obviously because he was a journalist he
had been at the pittsburgh courier he
ended up working with with afp um i
don't know that he painted
there's some indication if you read uh
hazel rowley's
uh biography of richard wright that
maria the the polish jewish survivor
is based on an ashkenazi jewish woman
who had been
a lover of richard wright and gardner
smith ended up
kind of stealing her from richard wright
um but i don't know
but otherwise their stories very much
diverge
gardner smith was was was married
through three times
um he was the the i think the the
parallels
are rather superficial in the end yeah
here's an interesting question um
bringing in yet
another identity group was smith in any
way aware of the piano
born in algeria for example
[Music]
estrangement was part of it of the
identity of the
do you think that estrangement can be a
concept linked with the kind of
feeling that goes on with racism
complex questions well the quinoa were
not quinoar
in 1971 right they they only became
quinoar when they were quote unquote
repatriated to france that's that's when
the term
emerges um
the the the uh there there is a
reference toward the end of the novel
uh to uh uh uh to french soldiers
returning home and to groups like the
oas
forming which were composed of comprised
obviously
of of of of ultra piano but
i i i don't think that he really
certainly he would have read kamuru um
no one
no writer was unfamiliar with camo's
works but i think the the the politics
the political vision that's espoused
here has has very little to do and in
fact it's almost antithetical
to camus vision
another complicated question why would
the protagonist want to exchange
one place of racism for another it seems
to me that the american experience can
be no place of exchange especially given
the legal racism that he would have met
upon his return well
let me respond to that um and
with a bit of an anecdote one of the
people i interviewed for my pope perry
noir was a woman who had been
a she was a black woman who'd been a
student in paris in the early 1960s
and she talked about how black students
from america at that time would come to
paris and meet with richard wright and
meet with all these people
but she said there was a difference
because rather than having the idea they
were going to sit at the feet of richard
wright and learn wisdom and and
great literature and all that they would
come and challenge him
and say why aren't you back in the
united states what are you doing here
why aren't you a part of the struggle
basically right um
and so i think this novel sort of
reflects that
that in effect people had a duty to be a
part of that struggle
um you know this is 1961 1962
uh the freedom rides are taking place in
the south for example there's all sorts
of violent incidents going on people are
literally putting their lives on the
line
and there's this idea that you know you
do not have the right to
you know sit here in paris and comfort
and talk about how terrible things are
i mean even even angela davis it's very
clear she's in frankfurt starting with
adorno
it's very clear she's eager to get back
that's a little
a little later quite a bit later still
the same urge
here's a here's a great question which
could be our last one
so what what do you guys think are the
textual and political stakes
of this forthcoming translation of the
stone faced into french
thinking for instance of how it would
interact with the
stora report which mentions the role of
re-editions and translations
and the current discussions of race in
france which
tend to dismiss intersectionality and
positionality as symptoms of the
americanization of french public debate
and we have one minute macron would say
it's the very first example of woke
culture from america invading france
right
except i can't think of a less workbook
yeah um i think it's gonna go i mean i
hope it goes off like something of a
of a bomb with no victims obviously um
it's it's an important book i think it's
going to be disturbing
[Music]
i think you know going back to something
adam said the question of how
anti-essentialist this book is that's
one of the big lessons to take away and
i would hope
somehow that would also uh inform the
debate
because i would hate to see it reduced
to a kind of essentialist debate such as
what do americans know about etc
um but i think to answer jean's question
i think the stakes are high
i hope it will have the visibility i
hope the translation will get the
visibility in france
for the stakes to play out um as i
mentioned i think in the context of the
the prostag it's very interesting to
have this account come to light in
france right now
invitation to write a critical essay in
french
on the book that's a wonderful place to
stop i thank you so much
for being here and for lending your
expertise
to the celebration thank you so much
thank you